-♪ Ooh! ♪
-♪ Ooh, ooh, yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Ooh, ooh, yeah ♪
♪ Ooh, ooh, yeah, yeah
Ooh, ooh, yeah ♪
♪ Kev'yn! Kev'yn ♪
♪ It's you and me
We family ♪
♪ Just tryin' to be
The best that we can be ♪
-♪ Kev'yn ♪
-♪ Oh! ♪
♪ So here we go
For what we know ♪
♪ Go with the flow
And get ready for the show ♪
-♪ Ooh, yeah! ♪
-♪ (HIP HOP BEAT PLAYING) ♪
So, I was separating the colors
from the whites,
but it felt too much
like segregation.
-(STUDIO LAUGHTER)
-So I just put 'em all together.
Would you just admit that women
have it harder than men,
and our bet... is off?
Men never say that.
And I'ma show you...
after I finish folding
your fine washables,
-and making these petit fours.
-(STUDIO LAUGHTER)
-(HUMMING)
-YOLANDA: Okay, man.
I don't want you putting
your hands on my underwear.
Who wants to touch
your dirty drawers?!
-(OVERLAPPING CHATTER)
-(KEV'YN CALLS OUT)
Percy, open the oven.
We ready, baby!
-(LAUGHS)
-(OVEN SIZZLING)
-Oh!
-Oh. Oh, no! Oh!
-(STUDIO LAUGHTER)
-(KEV'YN GRUNTS)
Oh!
Oh, hell to the naw.
-My Cornish hen!
-(STUDIO LAUGHTER)
-(SMOKE DETECTOR BEEPING)
-(GASPS)
(LAUGHS)
That's one small step
for womankind,
and one big slap across
the face... for Kev'yn.
-(STUDIO LAUGHTER)
-(GROANS)
-Do I smell boujee pigeon?
-(STUDIO LAUGHTER)
-(SIGHS) Lil' Chris...
What did I tell you about comin'
in my house through the fridge?
-Booyah!
-(STUDIO LAUGHTER)
-Don't make me come over there.
Huh? Huh?
Get outta here! Get!
-You... I hate you!
-(STUDIO LAUGHTER)
WOMAN VOCALIZING:
♪ Kev'yn! ♪
♪ Kev'yn ♪
♪ It's you and me
We family ♪
♪ Just tryin' to be
The best that we can be ♪
♪ Kev'yn ♪
♪ So here we go
For what we know ♪
♪ Go with the flow
And get ready for the show ♪
♪ Kev'yn ♪
♪ Oooh! ♪
Booyah!
♪ Kev'yn ♪
(STUDIO LAUGHTER)
-It is I, Colin Kaeper-nigga.
-(STUDIO LAUGHTER)
Ain't nobody got it harder
than brothas.
Hashtag "Knee Too."
(STUDIO LAUGHTER)
Well, sisters are the backbone
of this country.
And we're reclaiming
our "Time... Sup."
(STUDIO LAUGHTER)
Damn, Percy! What happened?
The pigs did it to me.
-Cops beat you?
-What?
Oh, naw.
Turns out I'm highly
allergic to pork.
(STUDIO LAUGHTER)
ANNOUNCER: Next time on...
♪ Kev'yn ♪
Forgive me,
because I am so bad with names.
You can call us
by our Wakanda names.
(STUDIO LAUGHTER)
-T'Challa.
-T'Choke-ya
(STUDIO LAUGHTER)
WOMAN VOCALIZING:
♪ Kev'yn ♪
♪ (HIP HOP BEAT PLAYING) ♪
(STUDIO LAUGHTER)
Now forgive me,
because I am so bad with names.
But it's... Yolanda, Kev-aisha,
and Kev-yen?
(STUDIO LAUGHTER)
Or you can call us
by our Wakanda names.
-T'Challa.
-T'Choke-ya.
"To choose to live your
white ass in another place."
-(HUFFING RHYTHMICALLY)
-(STUDIO LAUGHTER)
YOLANDA AND KEV'YSHA:
Kev'yn forever!
KEV'YN: Say it again!
BOTH: Kev'yn forever!
Please, join in.
Put down the greens.
Be a part of this, please.
Stand up! Move your shoulders!
-Yes! Not like a chicken!
-(STUDIO LAUGHTER)
-Come on!
-Kev'yn... forever...
-To the right. To the left.
-BOTH: Kev'yn forever!
-To the middle. To the middle!
-Yeah, walk it out.
-(STUDIO APPLAUSE)
NARRATOR: Next time on...
WOMAN VOCALIZING:
♪ Kev'yn ♪
My boy Percy was a good man.
STUDIO AUDIENCE: Aw!
(SIGHS HEAVILY)
He lost his life to ISIS.
That's what his ass get
for cheating on me.
Isis... don't... play!
(LAUGHS)
WOMAN VOCALIZING:
♪ Kev'yn ♪
♪ (HIP HOP BEAT PLAYING) ♪
(SNIFFLING)
My boy Percy was a good man.
STUDIO AUDIENCE: Aww!
(SIGHS)
He lost his life to ISIS.
That's what his ass get
for cheatin' on me.
-Isis... don't... play!
-(STUDIO LAUGHTER)
(STUDIO LAUGHTER CONTINUES)
Percy never returned
my Keith Sweat album, so...
he's been dead to me.
(STUDIO LAUGHTER)
If I could see Percy
one last time...
-(CASKET CREAKS)
-(EVERYONE GASPS)
Did somebody say repast?
(STUDIO LAUGHTER)
For real, Lil' Chris?
What did I tell you
about comin' in my house
through Percy's casket?
-(STUDIO LAUGHTER)
-Booyah!
Don't make me come over there.
-(STUDIO LAUGHTER)
-(SCATTERED APPLAUSE)
I still hate you!
(MURMURING)
(SHOUTING) I hate you!
(STUDIO LAUGHTER)
(APPLAUSE)
-ANNOUNCER: Next time on...
-♪ Kev'yn! ♪
I'm gonna watch
my favorite movie, Lean on Me.
Dad! Morgan--
Don't disrespect God
in this house, young lady.
(STUDIO LAUGHTER)
WOMAN VOCALIZING:
♪ Kev'yn ♪
♪ (HIP HOP BEAT PLAYING) ♪
-Hey, Kev'ysha!
-Hey, Daddy.
About to watch football.
Or, as I call it,
"Let Daddy Eat Whatever He Want
And Get Diabetes Day."
-(KEV'YN LAUGHS)
-(STUDIO LAUGHTER)
-Dad!
-Wha--
The NFL's cancelled. Stay woke.
Fine!
Alexa, play R. Kelly.
ALEXA: (ELECTRONIC VOICE)
Can't. Cancelled.
-Stay woke, Kev'yn.
-(STUDIO LAUGHTER)
Fine!
I'm gonna watch
my favorite movie,
-Lean on Me.
-Uh-uh.
"You smoke crack, don't 'cha?"
(LAUGHS) Crack is funny.
Dad!
Morgan played--
Don't disrespect God
in this house, young lady!
(IMITATING MORGAN FREEMAN)
Go to your room expeditiously!
(STUDIO LAUGHTER)
What's wrong with these kids?
That's a good movie.
(STUDIO LAUGHTER)
WOMAN VOCALIZING:
♪ Kev'yn ♪